Now, when you talk about God, your God
that you believe in.
Yeah. How many persons of God do you
believe in?
One.
A little louder.
One. One. Okay. Who is the spirit of God
in the Tanakh?
The spirit of God in in the Tanakh?
I don't I don't think there is a spirit
of God.
>> Okay. Isaiah 63:10.
What? Go to Isaiah 63:10. You said you
don't think there's a spirit of God in
Tanakh. Okay. Go to Isaiah 63:10.
What is that? Is that your drying your
washing machine?
What is that?
You said 63 10. Isaiah 63:10.
Okay.
Are you from Iraq or
My friend, don't change the subject,
dude. Can you go to Isaiah 63:10? My
ancestors are from Iraq. Stop it. Don't
talk that nonsense.
Isaiah 63:10, dude. Focus.
But they rebelled and grieved his holy
spirit.
>> They grieved who?
His holy spirit.
>> But I thought you said that there isn't
a spirit of God in the Tanakh.
Well, I don't know if this is about God
per se. I didn't I didn't ask you if
it's God. So, you're not listening. I
said, who is the spirit of God
in the Tanakh?
>> say the spirit of God. This says his
holy spirit.
>> So, when it says his holy spirit, who's
the his?
I don't know. I've never read this
chapter at all.
>> Okay. Well, here, I'm going to surprise
you.
Read verse 14 of the same chapter.
Verse 14.
Like a beast descending to the plains,
was the spirit of the Lord
>> So, are you going to stop your nonsense?
Because you just said it doesn't say the
spirit of God. Here it says the spirit
of the Lord. His holy spirit, the spirit
of the Lord, spirit of God is simply
different ways of saying the same thing.
So, are we to stop playing these games?
I feel uh there it is right there. So,
you're right.
>> Okay, thank you. And say it a little
louder. We can't hear you. What was it?
Uh like a beast descending to the plains
while the spirit of the Lord gave them
rest. And so, now you admit the spirit
of the Lord is his Holy Spirit. They're
simply different ways of saying the same
thing, right?
Uh yeah. Okay, so who's the spirit of
God now?
Uh God. Say it again.
God.
>> Okay, so the spirit of God is God even
though he belongs to God.
Yeah. Say it again. The spirit of God is
God though he belongs to God.
Yes. Yes, I'm glad you're saying yes.
And now let's count. Okay. Spirit of
God, spirit of God.
That's two, but the spirit is God. So,
how many gods do you have?
One. But you just said the spirit is God
and the spirit belongs to God. Last time
I checked, that sounds like two.
No.
Then what is it?
Are you okay? Don't ask me what I am.
I'm going by your Tanakh. I didn't use
the New Testament. Explain these
passages to me.
I mean, it's just saying that it was his
presence like
It's kind of like
>> How do you grieve presence? Presence is
not a person with emotions. It says they
grieved his Holy Spirit.
Yeah. So, God's presence it can be
grieved has emotions?
Uh
Can God's presence be grieved?
>> Yeah, well you just Hold on. Listen to
what you said. You said the spirit of
God is God's presence. But in verse 10
it says they grieved his Holy Spirit.
So, the Holy Spirit can be grieved. If
you grieve someone, that means they have
emotions. So, according to you, God's
spirit is God's presence who can be
grieved that has emotions. So, God's
presence has emotions? Read it. Isaiah
63:10. it's right there.
I mean, God definitely has emotions.
>> Yeah, but it says they grieved this Holy
Spirit. The Holy Spirit got grieved.
Yeah, maybe God was mad. I don't know.
I've never
>> You're not listening. It's not that God
was mad. It says the Holy Spirit was
hurt.
If the Holy Spirit is God's presence,
and yet God's presence can be hurt, that
means God's presence has emotions.
Listen to what you're saying. Read verse
10 again. Isaiah 63:10.
Okay, but they rebelled and grieved his
Holy Spirit.
>> So, it's not they grieved God. They
grieved his Holy Spirit. His Holy Spirit
was grieved.
Then he became their enemy and himself
made war against them. Okay, so you
agree now the Holy Spirit has emotions
cuz he can be grieved, right? God has
emotions. I never disagree. No, they
See, you're not listening.
The Holy Spirit has emotions, right?
Uh yeah. And the Holy Spirit belongs to
God, right?
Yes. And yet you said the Holy Spirit is
Yes. Do the math. Holy Spirit belongs to
God.
Holy Spirit and God, that's two, but the
Holy Spirit is God. So, how many gods do
you worship? One is God and that's a
tautology, so that's one. God so and God
and the Spirit are still one?
That's a tautology, so yes. Uh you're
using terms incorrectly, but that's
okay. God and his Spirit are still one,
right?
Yes.
>> But even though the Spirit belongs to
God, so he's different from God, right?
No.
Wait. So, when it says
they grieved his Holy Spirit and the
Spirit of the Lord was in their midst.
Who was in their midst? God or his
Spirit? Cuz that's verse 11. Isaiah
63:11.
I can see the Spirit. I mean, that's
what it says. Okay, so
Yeah.
>> Just like when you say his people,
his temple,
his city, his spirit. Now, when I say
his people, that means the people are
not God, they're different, right?
Yeah, Israel. Just like it says his
spirit, that means the spirit is
different from God, right?
No. Oh, wait. Hold on. Read Isaiah
63:10. Read it again.
Okay. Read one more time slowly.
is
but they rebelled and grieved his Holy
Spirit. Then he became their enemy and
himself made war against them. Okay, so
now read verse 11.
Then they remembered the ancient days,
him who pulled his people out of the
water. Okay, his people. Wait, wait. He
did what to his for who? His people.
Right?
Yeah. Okay, now let me ask you a
question just logically. When I say his
people, that means the people are not
him. They belong to him, right?
Yeah. So, his Holy Spirit means Holy
Spirit is not him, he belongs to him,
right?
No. Well, dude, it's right in front of
you. If his people
means they're not him but belong to him,
his people
>> God, I'm Israel, I'm part of his people,
but That's my point. So, when you say
his people, that means the people he
owns. So, when you say his Holy Spirit,
that means Holy Spirit that belongs to
him. There's a distinction. It's right
there.
Yeah, it's not the actual dude.
If the It actual dude.
>> if Hashem came down to Earth, he would
destroy the entire planet.
>> Okay, so if I show you Hashem coming
down to the Earth, are you going to say
that Rabbi Tovia Singer is a dog?
Uh no. Okay, go to Exodus 24:9-11.
Yeah. Exodus 24:9-11. Cuz you just said
Hashem, God, come down to Earth, the
Earth will be burned up. Okay, now
explain to me Exodus 24:9-11.
When you get there, let me know, read
it.
You said 19? Exodus 24 verses 9 to 11.
Chapter 24 verses 9 to 11.
Then Moses and Aaron, Nadab and Abihu,
and 70 elders of Israel ascended, and
they saw the God of Israel. Who did they
see? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Who did
they see?
The God of Israel. They saw the God of
Israel. Now, read what else they saw.
Keep reading.
Under his feet there was the likeness
So, you're saying God has feet?
Uh, no. No, what Dude, it's in front of
your eyes. They saw under his feet what
looked like pavement of sapphire.
What are you talking about?
I mean, it makes sense when he was sent
to heaven, right?
>> No, it's not in heaven. He's come down
to the Mount Sinai.
They're not in heaven. This is on Earth
in the wilderness, Mount Sinai.
Read it again now, verses 9 to 11.
Exodus 24 verses 9 to 11.
Out loud so we can hear you.
Uh, then Moses and Aaron, Nadab and
Abihu, and the 70 elders of Israel
ascended.
Keep going.
And they saw the God of Israel. Louder.
Why is it now your voice went down?
Louder, say with passion.
>> And they saw the God of Israel. Keep
going.
Under his feet there was the likeness of
pavement of sapphire.
Like the very sky of purity that he did
not raise his hand against the leaders
of his of the Israelites.
They beheld God and they ate and drank.
And to prove to you it's not in heaven,
you just read 11 they beheld God and ate
and drank. What happens when you read
now 12 to 18?
Moses goes up to the mount where God's
cloud has come down on Mount Sinai. This
is not in heaven, it's on earth.
No, it's in heaven. Read it again. Read
now 12 to 18. I know the text, please do
not butcher it. It's on earth on the
mount. That's why God's going to tell
them
>> hold on. Go back to back to nine first.
Yeah, read nine again. They ascended to
the mount. It's the context. Brother,
don't argue with me. Read.
>> say the mount. It just says they
ascended. Keep reading.
And they saw the God of Israel. Under
his feet there was the likeness of
pavement of sapphire. Yep. Very sky of
purity. Keep going.
Yet they did not raise his hand yet.
Keep going.
>> raise his hand against the leaders of
the Israelites. Go. They
Huh? Keep reading. Go, don't stop. They
beheld God and they ate and drank. Read
the next verse.
The Lord said to Moshe, come up to near
the mountain and wait there. Come up to
me where?
To the mountain. BUT YOU JUST SAID NO,
it's not on the mountain.
Yeah.
But he just told you God just said
you're lying. I am on the mountain, you
come up, they don't come up. That's
verse.
My friend, do you want to start from
one? You're See now you're playing games
cuz you're a liar. Okay, read from verse
one. Read from No, no, no. Read from
verse one.
>> I'll shut up. I'll shut up. Read from
verse one. You want to read the entire
Are you going to just stop being
deceptive and say, "Okay, man. It says
what it says. This is God in the Sinai
wilderness when he brought my ancestors
out of Egypt." That's the context, dude.
Stop butchering your text, man.
I'm not. I read it as it says. Okay,
good. So now, how could they see God
with feet and a pavement under his feet?
I thought you said God would consume
them.
No, they ascended to heaven. No, it
doesn't say that. Read from verse one.
Read the entire chapter. Read from verse
one.
Then he said to Moshe, "Come up to the
Lord with Aaron, Nadab, and Abihu, and
the 70 elders of Israel,
and bow low from afar. Moshe alone came.
Moshe alone shall come near the Lord,
but the others shall not come near,
nor shall the people come up with them."
Moshe went and told
>> people went up to heaven?
Uh no.
>> Okay, keep on. Keep reading.
Moshe went and repeated to the people
all the commands of the Lord and all the
rules, and all the people answered with
one voice, saying,
"All the things that the Lord has
commanded we will do." Little louder, my
friend. Leader louder and slowly, and
pay attention. Louder, so they can hear
you. Your mic is going up. Louder and
slowly, and pay attention. Read the
entire chapter. I'm not going to stop
you. Keep reading.
Don't stop. Keep reading.
Moshe went and repeated to the people
all the commands of the Lord and all the
rules,
and all the people answered with one
voice, saying, "All the things that the
Lord has commanded we will do." Moshe
then wrote down all the commands of the
Lord. Early in the morning, he set up an
altar
at the foot of the mountain with 12
pillars
>> At the foot of the what?
The mountain. Oh, so they're in heaven?
There's a mountain in heaven?
Not at this point.
>> Okay, well, keep reading. Cadet, no
point they're in heaven, but nice try.
But keep reading.
Okay.
The 12 pillars for the 12 tribes of
Israel. He designated some young men
among the Israelites, and they offered
burnt offerings and sacrificed bulls as
offerings of well-being to the Lord.
Moshe took one part of the blood and put
it in basins, and the other part of the
blood he dashed against the altar.
Then he took the record of the covenant
and read it aloud to the people,
and they said, "All the Lord All that
the Lord has spoken we will faithfully
do."
Moshe took the blood and dashed it on
the people and said, "This is the blood
of the covenant that the Lord now makes
with you concerning all these commands."
And Moshe and Aaron, Nadab and Abihu,
the 70 elders of Israel ascended.
And they saw the God of Israel.
Under his feet there was the likeness of
pavement of sapphire, like the sky like
the very sky of purity.
Yet he did not raise his hand against
the leaders of the Israelites. They
beheld God and they ate and drank.
The Lord said to Moshe, "Come up to me
Come up to me on the mountain and wait
there, and I will give you the stone
tablets with the teachings and
commandments
which I have inscribed to instruct
them." So Moshe and his attendant Joshua
arose,
and Moshe ascended the mountain of God.
To the elders he said, "Wait here for us
until we return to you. You have Aaron
and Hur with you. Let anyone who has a
legal matter approach them." Then Moshe
had ascended the mountain, and the crowd
>> heaven or the mountain?
The mountain. Keep going.
The presence of the Lord abode on Mount
Sinai, and the cloud hid it for six
days. On the seventh day he called to
Moshe from the midst of the cloud.
Now the presence of the Lord appeared in
the sight of the Israelites as a
consuming fire on top of the mountain.
On top of heaven or on the mountain?
The mountain. And where was this
mountain? In heaven or is it in the
wilderness?
Uh the Mount Sinai. Okay, keep reading.
Excuse me.
Moses went inside the cloud and ascended
the mountain and Moses remained on the
mountain 40 days and 40 nights. Okay.
Now, you see, ascended means ascend the
mountain where God had come down in a
cloud.
Can you show me anywhere in that chapter
it says ascending to heaven?
Uh, it just says they ascended. And in
the context, if you just don't take one
verse out of context, my brother, like
you accuse Christians of doing. I'm
giving you the entire chapter, you're
taking one word.
Did you hear it says ascend to the
mountain? Ascend to the mountain?
Yeah, it says that in later verses, but
it doesn't say
>> Where in the context does it change
ascension to At this point, you can now
jump to heaven and come back down to
earth to go up the mountain. Are you
being ridiculous here?
No, I'm not. The Lord can pull you up
and put you back in the Where
>> Where does it say he pulled them up to
heaven when he just said those other 70,
"Don't let them get near the mountain."
But he's going to let them enter heaven.
So, let's let's go with your logic.
Well, let's go with your logic.
"You 70, you can come to heaven. But
when I bring you back to earth, don't
you dare get near the mountain where I'm
at, cuz you just spent some time with me
in heaven, but you can't do it on
earth." You see how you sound?